I wanted to ask you about military
intervention and War and all that stuff
I know that you are one of the biggest
opponents of the US getting involved
overseas and I'm curious your thoughts
on where we've gone since you were in
Congress has it gotten worse and what
your views are
well the principle has gotten much worse
they've endorsed the the principle and
uh the big thing was uh probably one
that is is annoying to me was uh because
I remember it and that was we had World
War One World War II and we went through
the you know the process of declaring
war and having an enemy and it did
I think they could have been avoided but
but it was done the right way in a sense
that we declared the war and the wars
didn't last that long we were only an
hour a year or so on a World War One in
World War II is three years let's think
of how that was taken care of but after
the war and I remember this uh this uh
issue very clearly because it was in 51
50 51 you know when uh when Truman said
oh he never probably made an
announcement we have to have a police
action we have to go and you know
preserve democracy for Korea and my
comparison was yeah and look we wanted
to do that in South Korea and uh we we
lose 60 000 people and kill millions of
the Vietnamese and all this and then we
lose and we walk away lost all this
money in all these lives and what
happened was there a uh this these are
just realistic arguments but uh it was
was there the domino effect that's what
we were preached to your domino effect
it's going to Communism is going to take
over and they did a lot of that but
guess what when we lost the war in
Vietnam we we left and uh all of a
sudden something weird happened uh they
started acting like capitalists
and and just think of all we want in
peace versus all that we lost in war and
sometimes people won't even think of the
slightest consideration that maybe a
little bit of that philosophy could be
applied to those people who are looking
forward to a war with China
I feel like it's it's like a Chinese
finger trap that you've got so many
people who want war and they make the
argument we need to go there to stop
Russia we need to go there to to stop
the terrorists but in doing these things
in engaging in foreign intervention it's
creating recoil or creating blowback and
it's making the conflicts worse it's
making it's by Design I mean that's what
keeps the machine running you know
that's what keeps the money flowing we
talk about the FED all the time the FED
is what makes War possible is what makes
the Empire possible and it's funny
because you sit around and you laugh at
the Domino thing oh man that's that's
like you know that's like something out
of the 60s we're living in it right now
if we don't stop Russia in Ukraine
they're going to be marching through
Paris you know tomorrow they're gonna
they're gonna take Estonia where's
Estonia I have no idea but they're going
to take it
so we still believe in the Domino Theory
it's still the basis of our foreign
policy in fact who was it it was a
politician it actually may have been
McCarthy speaker of the house and I
could be wrong who said um well we got
to fight him basically he literally said
we got to find him over there because
otherwise we're going to find him over
here I mean I thought the bush era was
over right so these things are just
regurgitated because they're enormously
profitable to the most well-connected
people you know the only value I see to
in foreign intervention is that fascism
sometimes can be extremely peaceful
that's one of the worst things about
fascism is it's insidiously quiet I mean
modern fascism it's it's capitalists
they buy they they run your social media
they make you see things you don't
understand and so at some point if you
don't do anything it will just will
happen around you let me try to
elaborate on what you're I think what
you're saying is what we're seeing with
big Tech what we're seeing with the
establishment this authoritarian
takeover subverting our systems buying
people out and slowly creeping and
taking things over is that yeah
BlackRock these these Mega corporations
that are buying land and things like
that's that's it's happening in the name
of Peace because it's they're being done
with dollars but I don't I don't know if
fascism is the right word because some
people might take the word fascism
literally but we're seeing you know
state with State Street Vanguard
BlackRock corporatism corporatism
they're buying everything up there using
the system against us and exploiting it
and it's not just that these these big
uh uh hedge funds and and firms they're
getting Federal Reserve money basically
infinitely printed and given to them to
do this so it's the lucrative I guess
fascism is probably the right way to say
it the lucrative merger of Corporation
and state to to take over the whole
system under Mussolini's definition and
I think you are correct in some some
instances there especially with a lot of
these institutions like BlackRock having
lucrative contracts now in Ukraine
there's a lot of business deals there's
a lot of politicians Sons and Daughters
who have a lot of interests in that
particular region but I kind of wanted
to ask both of you guys if you guys were
the Secretary of State how do you handle
the Ukraine situation right now what's
the call call to action
well I have a real easy thing to do it's
not complex and everybody will
understand it but nobody will do it
because I used it in my debates you know
how are we going to end the wars in the
Middle East yeah we've sort of come
around to your position we should have
done it but here we are we're there and
I and my answer is we just marched in we
can just March out yes and I remember uh
you had a statement where you said if
someone is given the wrong prescription
you don't just keep giving them the same
prescription you stop that sounds pretty
good did I say that you did say that yes
it's brilliant and I heard that and I
said I don't see it any other way if we
all agree it's wrong we just stop
yeah and I think it's fair to say that
uh they've been prescribed crack crack
cocaine and heroin and Fentanyl all
mixed into one and they're high as a
kite and they're they're doing really
horrible things especially with with
what's happening in Ukraine right now
there's so many innocent ukrainians
dying there's so many innocent young men
dying in that specific region and and I
think you know the main reason we didn't
blow each other up during the Cold War
was as was because of negotiations was
was because we were able to actually sit
at the table and negotiate we're not
even doing that now which which is just
absurd and crazy in my opinion I asked
him last night what he would do and he
was like Well we'd be like we'd take our
troops out and negotiate some sort of
economic you know resolution with Russia
and I don't know Ron do you think that
that would be ethical to because I think
what they're trying to do is take
sevastopol the the warm water trade port
in the Black Sea yeah but by what
happens when there's sincere efforts
either with China or Russia that we
could pursue uh I mean the Deep state
which is uh not Republican not Democrat
they're deep into controlling the whole
system they make it so that you you
become a heathen you become a Nazi or
you they'll give you all kinds of names
you know uh and you're unpatriotic
that's the thing I was when I wanted to
bring the troops home I was unpatriotic
and I didn't care about the troops I
said how could you argue that I just
want to bring them home so they don't
get killed yeah more more troops donated
to you than any other presidential
candidate people forget about that and
you were one of the only anti-war voices
out there that was finally getting at
least a little bit of attention on the
corporate media even though it was
skewed even though when you're polling
high they made sure that they looked
like you were polling low they played so
many underhanded tricks against you I
was wondering um Can can you talk to
that a little bit and and how do we
navigate this media sphere when they
control the narrative and they're
playing so unfair
well I I still I resort to something
that I find my comfort zone and that is
that I'm not there I I don't have the
ability nor is the support there to
really change it you know uh I want to
audit the Fed so people understand it I
don't say okay the litmus test if you
care about anything at all you have to
sign on to my bill that the Federal
Reserve is abolished in two weeks you
know and and so I I wanted people just
have to you know discuss it and that's
what happens it gets turned down we have
opportunity we could talk to China a lot
more you know I thought it was pretty
exciting when uh when the Great Nixon
decided to sneak over to China and it
was an exciting time people think boy
you know maybe they will change and they
did but the big problem is that we won't
admit is they'd be paying pretty darn
good at capitalism some you know they've
sold us stuff and they took our money
and invested it and uh and what do we do
we steal the money from the people and
then we've invested to the
military-industrial complex could go
over and drop bombs on people then we
say I wonder why they don't like us I've
been thinking lately if we could
repurpose our military industrial
complex to start building drones in like
by the tens of millions and then take
them out into space and blow them up for
training and then put on board
Artificial Intelligence on the drones
the drones can tell us what we're doing
wrong make us better at fighting drone
swarms and then we can not blow people
up because I think I still want to make
it profitable for Lockheed Martin but I
don't want to hurt the people with
Lockheed Martin okay let me try I I
think you come you bring up an actual
interesting point and I'll put it I'll
rephrase it I think I think I understand
the military industrial complex is going
to move towards the path of least
resistance and that is they need War to
stay in power and and they want war so
they Lobby for war they get more money
from the government so what we need is
to divert their profits into nonsense
like building drones sent outer space so
they keep getting lucrative contracts
but eventually fizzle out of existence
because they're they're being given
money for the government to do literally
nothing thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time